Maxwell here another gamespot news
update where respawn has announced that
titanfall is getting a massive update
today across all platforms and will add
in a bunch of new features you fans have
been asking for the biggest addition is
the inclusion of private matches you
will be able to start a private match by
selecting it from the main screen and
you can invite your friends or have them
join at any time private matches support
any and all of titan falls maps and
modes private matches won't gain you any
XP challenge progress or unlock any
achievements on the website respawn said
some features are unfinished or not yet
implemented and we welcome your feedback
in future patches you will be able to
adjust round time score limit and much
more other changes include fixing the
exploit that was used for a certain type
of wall hack cheat a series of balance
changes that affect achievements weapon
magazine size and damage and even the
scoring system on hard point domination
and capture the flag matches some
details were revealed on future updates
including rename abul custom loadout
slots that are 120 Hertz monitor support
other private match customization
options and more and of course you can
check out the complete list of titanfall
updates over I gamespot com